los primeros idea knows no DC Anamika
Ayano c'mere tortilla anoke americano de
se fueron communicant oh no al otro
Kelly yeah 7 dias O'Meara idea not equal
como empezar on Malaga you know recently
a case on padrecito di t Amiga
[Music]
mean hombres Rosie Castillo e Co cinemas
comedian back in a lunch area who's da
da Tiana's vijnana pere foucault
Estados Unidos pero es hora de encontrar
una mala noticia que ya no los de carros
pasa mucho decidieron kadar cnt1
nosotros somos los primeros egg hacer la
comida en muchos de chillon Amiga Yo no
tengo dinero no Trejo les damos la
comida tambien a loss primary Tito's
Supriyo mucho SE Hagar Oh muchos Sinden
arrows in ropa por que se no Rabanne oun
todo y por no tremie Co V cos Y del
demos Kobe hazaki Rita yeah same Ovidio
socia self in yo el arroz blanco poncho
[ __ ] Manny today Puerco en leg in la
mayoría que la comida esta cosa Oh si
Yoshiko mem picante pero no kimono so
troll okoma son Besson Posehn muy
diferente a la de nosotros hay algo que
hay una caída - tierra que sabe que que
lo vas a comer algo de - pies from
muchas veces no dicen in a wallet alwa
crc esa forma de vecinos casino Sentra
sentimiento SI los últimos que se fueron
vinieron he knows Dobbin las Gracia
leggin oligo con que yo me stays at a
yuusaku steady Savin contentos con ellos
tenían Pagano
people need to understand that all of
North America is indigenous land it is
native land people tend to forget that
there was a vibrant native culture
living in all parts of North America and
food is really the piece that's going to
help us move forward into a brighter
future my name is Sean Sherman and I am
a chef I own the company of the
sous-chef so this is going to be two
pieces per plate for these our mission
is revitalizing Native American foods
and re-identifying North American
cuisine we've tried really hard to
maintain authenticity by removing all of
the colonial ingredients like dairy
wheat flour processed sugar beef pork
chicken and we're just using a lot of
wild game a lot of the native
agricultural heirloom bridles a lot of
the wild foods around us and are really
making those plates that tastes like a
region
most of these ingredients are very
familiar to people but the usage of a
lot of the wild plants really talked
about a place in a community
[Music]
we prioritize purchasing from the
indigenous vendors first because we
really want to open up a lot of
opportunity for indigenous people
growing out firearms or collecting
things from the wild or raising animals
so for the big dinner we're actually
cooking this bison down with a bunch of
fresh cedar and some bergamot we will
purchase from anybody raising these
indigenous pieces because it is such an
important part of the landscape in the
history you know you want it as we
travel around the country we like to
make dinners and foods that really
represent those areas what's great about
being able to do these dinners
especially in non-indigenous communities
is just to bring awareness this kind of
food that we're eating today like you're
gonna feel really good when you leave
here you're not gonna feel heavy and
weighted down you're gonna feel
energized and just happy because you're
knowing where this food is coming from
we feel like anybody across North
America will benefit from the
understanding of the indigenous food
systems around you and it's all going to
help us move forward
you
I am Illya chase the chef and co-owner
of Dooky Chase's restaurant I've liked
you for years old I've been in this
kitchen 71 years every day I come at
this kitchen 7:30 in the morning I hit
this floor and I don't leave until we
close but guests come to this city they
know where they come here they get to
get a good pull of Creole gumbo they're
gonna get some jambalaya think it get
some good fried chicken
they're gonna get with ourselves the
butter just melted and give it all kinds
of good flavor every day I meet new
people and they come to taste the food I
cook that makes you feel good this place
back in the day was the label we just
came a meeting plates in the civil
rights movement and so you had always
Thurgood Marshall Ernest right all those
big NAACP people black people knew they
can come to Dooky Chase's and will not
be disturbed by anybody it was illegal
whites and blacks to be together but
they came here this was a safe haven for
all of us
I fed mr. Obama he was gonna eat the
gumbo and he gets the hot sauce back
oh my god I said mr. Obama you don't put
hot dog bun gumbo now that gets around
all the neighborhood so they said you
told him good mr. key don't be messing
up your cup that was recognized by James
Reed with the Lifetime Achievement Award
to be that was unbelievable
sometimes I said I don't know how I got
here
but it gives you energy to keep going
and my whole thing is to make this
restaurant go I want to be one of the
best restaurant there is
you
[Music]
we all crave our grandmother's cooking
right well what if there were a place
that you could go anytime and get that
home-cooked meal from anywhere in the
world
Mangia Mangia Mangia Mangia that place
exists in Staten Island just behind that
scaffolding right over there
[Music]
meet Joe he's Italian by way of Brooklyn
my name is Jody scarab Ella and I own
Enoteca Maria we don't employ chefs we
employ grandmothers when Joe up in the
restaurant in 2006 he noticed something
every culture was coming to the
restaurant to celebrate these Italian
grandmothers so I thought to myself
unless would it be if we celebrated it
everybody's culture and so Nonna's of
the world was born they are probably
somewhere between 30 and 40 grandmothers
from different countries
my name is Habiba I from Nigeria my name
is Luca Finland from Moscow Russia so it
was Apple their bingo they leave my
parents come from Sri Lanka Vulgaria
Dublin Ireland from our menu window
sorry this Argentina each night there
are two grandmother's cooking one is
always Italian the other from somewhere
else when they're in the kitchen cooking
it's a completely different energy it's
their day to shine it's their day to
show what their cultural cuisine is all
about you know it sounds kind of corny
but they do cook with love and then
feeling for Jose about more than the
restaurant when I opened the Enoteca I
was really grief-stricken
my mom and my sister had passed it was
comforting to have these grandmother's
in the kitchen cooking and you know they
would pinch my cheek and say you want to
try this and at that point I realized
that what we were doing was much bigger
than I thought it was going to be when
you walk through the restaurant if you
listen every table that you pass by
they're talking about their mothers or
they're talking about their grandmothers
it kind of evokes a trip down memory
lane
[Music]
[Music]
we've been called crazy a lot of times
by a lot of different people we were
coming with something that nobody had
ever put on the table before so people
didn't know how to react
my name is Camilla Sadler we're in
Bolivia in La Paz in restaurant gusto
where I'm the executive head chef the SU
is crazy restaurant on a mountain it
started out as a small culinary school
projects and then we decided to go big
founded by globally celebrated chef
close Maya
gusto is a unique culinary experiment in
social outreach the goal proving that
food can do more than just feed people
it can educate and inspire one of the
poorest countries in Latin America but
with an abundance of diverse and obscure
ingredients Bolivia seemed to be the
perfect spot to set up shop
the idea of giving something back in a
development country is where gusu comes
into the picture
Guster's goal is to train a new
generation of the Libyans to cook
prepare and serve high-end cuisine using
only Bolivian ingredients goose is not
meant to be a typical culinary school
it's meant to be a learning by doing
Institute education needs to come with
with care you can educate somebody if
you don't care about them mean hombres
Mario hanya pasa tormenta soy supervisor
edema serous heat ambien mr. M [ __ ]
dumbass and ilaria the so malaria the
momentum K centric e basket o is
productive Olivia no que ninguna otra
lado de Gama slow antibiotics 'history
bear K goes to low H good to a cambiar
mi vida there's a lot of potential
there's a lot of energy there's a lot of
pride one of the big things we're doing
is empowering people yes it's a movement
that that touches the whole society
you